today on the matt walsh show woke virtue
signaling at the oscars is overshadowed
by will smith's violent cuckold rage
we'll talk about that also the white
house calls for regime change in russia
and then says that it's not calling for
regime change in russia plus videos
circulate allegedly showing the torture
and murder of russian pows and cory
booker is still shocked and appalled and
heartbroken that kantanji jackson was
asked to define the word woman plus a
lesbian couple sues a fertility clinic
after giving birth to a boy instead of a
girl in our daily cancellation i'm
forced to cancel televangelist joel and
victoria osteen i'll explain why all of
that and more today on the matt wells
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well as we all know inflation is out of
control and it's not projected to get
better any time soon that's why it's
never been more important to rethink how
we shop and choose brands that are
effective safe and in it for the long
haul our partner naturally it's clean
can help naturally clean is dedicated to
providing the most effective cleaning
products for your home while reducing
your costs reducing your waste and
reducing other harmful chemicals in your
home as well their safer chemistry
solutions utilize nature's powerful
plant-based enzymes to clean every area
of your home from the bathroom to your
hardwood floors to your kitchen
now you might be wondering
what does it have to do with inflation
well natural it's clean is here to help
you save big on the cleaning solutions
you use every day by offering many of
their top cleaning solutions as a
concentrate formula many of their
concentrated solutions will yield 12
bottles driving down the cost per bottle
and allowing you to save big in the
meantime and giving your budget the
break that it definitely deserves so try
them for yourself right now my listeners
can get their hands on the naturally
it's clean daily wire essential kit
stocked with four great products for
fifteen percent off simply visit
naturallyitsclean.com
matt and use promo code matt to save an
additional 15 off your order don't delay
a break from bidenflation is here try
out these incredible cleaning products
in your home today by is it visiting
naturallyitsclean.com for more
information
so i want to begin today with an
exciting announcement last week we told
you about my upcoming film what is a
woman which chronicles my journey to
answer the question of a generation the
question that so many people are now
asking along the way i find myself
tumbling down the gender ideology rabbit
hole where i discover many disturbing
and horrifying things yet so much of it
is also hilarious in the in the darkest
way possible
that film will be out in may now
in much less important news the oscars
were held last night it was an event
that passed almost an almost entirely
without notice if not for one incident
which we'll discuss in a moment before
we get there
it's worth reflecting on the fact that
awards shows used to be ratings bonanzas
i mean there was a time in the not too
distant past when 40 million people 50
million people would sit around their
televisions on a sunday night and watch
a bunch of wealthy drug addicts give
themselves awards for five hours
those days are long gone
soon the era of televised award shows
will be officially over they'll no
longer exist at all
and our children will look at us with
bewilderment when we explain that once
upon a time we used to actually watch
celebrities give speeches about how
great celebrities are
they will certainly find that confusing
i have always found it confusing and i
live through that era in history myself
the reasons for the disintegration of
the once popular awards show genre are
many
one obvious factor is that the films
nominated and awarded are increasingly
obscure
last night apparently something called
coda won best picture nobody has seen
this movie nobody there there is a
debate raging right now about whether
the movie even technically exists nobody
knows
if it does nobody knows where to find it
it seems that they just gave best
picture to
a movie that exists only as a
hypothetical like a theory it's an
abstract concept
and this is a reflection of the deeper
problem
hollywood infected with a terminal case
of wokeness
is more and more insular with each
passing day it's obsessed
with itself with its own moral
superiority
and that tremendous sense of
self-righteousness has caused it to
collapse in on itself
one of the consequences of wokeness is
that it obstructs a person's ability to
see beyond themselves
and this is true for anybody who
subscribes to this cult or is
indoctrinated by it but the effect is
amplified by a million
in hollywood because its denizens are
are already living lives of
incomprehensible privilege
these people are already artificial
basically self-obsessed over-indulged
coddled
you can see why they're all leftists
it is a world view made for them and
also in large part made by them
they're not interested in even
pretending otherwise anymore now they
used to pretend they used to at least
pretend there's always been the
indoctrination the leftist
indoctrination from hollywood but it
used to be a lot more subtle they used
to pretend anyway to you know um to be
trying to appeal to a larger audience to
be able to relate to a larger audience
that is over now
last night judging by the clips that i
saw online anyway because of course i
didn't like everybody else i didn't
actually watch the show
they kicked things off by going
political right away wasting no time
just planting the flag right away this
is what it's about and of course the
first item on the woke agenda was to
virtue signal about the fictional don't
say gay bill that leftists have invented
watch
we're gonna have a great night uh
tonight and for you people in florida
we're gonna have a gay night
[Applause]
what courage what courage i mean it's
hard to fathom the bravery required to
stand on stage
in front of a room full of gay people
and say the word gay over and over again
this is this is what heroism is all
about and they kept playing the hits you
know later in the monog monologue they
threw in a bit about toxic masculinity
and also mitch mcconnell listen
you know this year we saw a frightening
display of how toxic masculinity turns
into cruelty towards women and children
damn that mitch mcconnell i know
yeah because
when you think of toxic masculinity the
first person that comes to mind is
mitch mcconnell
a little later in the night hispanic
actor john lugazano liguizamo took the
stage to applaud hollywood's
representation and all of the
beautiful
latinx faces listen
look at all these beautiful faces out
here
all these beautiful latinx faces we got
great representation here tonight people
oh sorry not not latinx latinx yeah
i always forget how to pronounce that
made-up word i'm not exactly sure what a
what a latinx face looks like seeing as
how there's no such thing as a latinx
person
latinx at best sounds like the name of a
of a hispanic-only fan's site it's
certainly not the name for a group of
people especially because
if this sort of thing is important to
you
there are already numerous gender
neutral terms available to describe that
group terms like hispanic or even just
latin
but again wokeness is insular
self-referential
it's gibberish to anyone who is not
already fully indoctrinated into it
that's why the left has to work so hard
and so desperately to indoctrinate
children into the cult because they know
that adults who grew up in saner times
are increasingly turned off by this sort
of thing
and are rapidly tuning it out in a
literal sense when it comes to the
oscars
that is people were tuned out
until the smack heard round the world
now you've no doubt already seen this
clip but let's all watch it again for
entertainment's sake if nothing else
watch
he is praying that will smith wins like
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i jane jump keep my
wife's name out
i'm going to
okay
well i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay
truly the most atrocious thing will
smith has done since the aladdin remake
uh it's i mean this guy learned nothing
at all after spending all that time with
his auntie and uncle in bel air
on the positive side however
smith's physical assault of chris rock
completely overshadowed and drowned out
all of the virtue signaling that came
before it you know all the lgbt stuff
they had all the ukraine stuff and like
all that's out the window
the celebrities in attendance wanted the
story to be about them heroically
chanting the word gay wearing blue
ribbons in support of ukraine
they didn't want this to be the story
that's also why you shouldn't buy into
any conspiracy theories that the
incident was staged okay it was not
that's that's a more absurd
idea
than the incident itself was now maybe
the vma circa 1997 may have staged
something like this but not the woke
oscars of 2022
this is entirely real
and we should admit the most
entertaining thing that's happened at
any awards show in at least 25 years
personally i might actually start
watching these things if the whole show
was just a bunch of celebrities beating
the hell out of each other on stage like
a really well-dressed version of
celebrity death match
but as fun as it may be to watch
that was nonetheless a physical assault
which was committed on national
television in front of literally dozens
of viewers
something tells me that if you or i had
walked onto stage during an event of
that kind
or any other kind and committed assault
against a presenter right in front of
everybody we'd be in handcuffs within 15
seconds instead will smith sat back down
enjoyed the rest of the show even won
best actor later in the evening
where he proceeded to cry and paint
himself as the victim of the physical
assault that he just committed listen
[Applause]
richard williams
was a fierce
defender of his family
i'm being called on
in my life
to love people
and to protect people
and to be a river to my people
i mean scientology really messes with
your brain uh just don't don't try it
kids even once
only in hollywood can a man assault
another man and then 20 minutes later
give a tearful speech about the power of
love
i'm a river to my people by smacking
chris rock
also keep something else in mind will
smith and this is the most important
thing about this incident to keep in
mind um he has bragged publicly on
multiple occasions about the fact that
his wife sleeps with other men
he has long been out of the cuckold
closet very open about the fact fact
that his wife enjoys jumping in bed with
strange men so any temptation you might
feel to take his side to argue that this
was a husband defending his wife's honor
as i've seen like a few people a few
conservatives even have said well this
is this is right this is traditional
values the traditional values he's in an
open he's a cuckold in an open marriage
with this woman he laughed at the joke
at first and then looked over at his
wife scowling and said oh
this was him
doing it primarily
as this was another act of of
emasculation by him
and any
temptation you have to defend him must
be mitigated by the fact that to will
smith defending his wife's honor does
not include preventing other men from
having sex with her so you can
you
you dare not joke about his wife but you
can't have sex with her now that's a man
of principle
as a couple there's no honor left to
defend he doesn't have any neither does
she
how can he defend what doesn't exist
but then again they did award best
picture to a movie that doesn't exist so
who knows anymore
it's clear that the smack was not an
honorable man fiercely defending his
wife from an extremely mild joke about
her hair it was rather a privileged yet
broken and emasculated man lashing out
like a spoiled child and doing what no
normal person in this country would be
allowed to do and get away with it
he did what he did for his own sake
because he could
later that night he was filmed at an
after party
dancing and singing
while a crowd cheered him on
you or i would be sitting in a jail cell
right now still
he was at an oscar's party prancing
around with his golden statue
apparently the trauma he suffered from
chris rock's joke
was not enough to prevent him from
dancing you know a golden statue can
heal even the deepest wounds i suppose
now given that this was black on black
violence and both men involved are
fairly liberal you may be wondering
whose side the woke crowd would take
because it's not maybe not not
immediately clear how this is all going
to shake out
but then when you think about it there's
no real mystery
one of the central tenets of leftism is
that words especially words in the form
of jokes are violence
i mean they hate stand-up comedians the
most and so of course assaulting a
stand-up comedian they love that
the emerging consensus on the left
therefore is that will smith was
justified because chris rock's joke was
a form of violence this was self-defense
against a violent attack by a comedian
that's the justification anyway as
offered even by prominent politicians
like ayanna presley and jamal bowman but
the real justification is that will
smith is a non-white left-wing hollywood
celebrity and so he's allowed to do
things that the rest of us peons cannot
do
that is the privilege of leftism
an ideology that in so many ways exists
in its own universe
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the other we got to move on
from this but um
the other great thing about what
happened last night
is that and i also want to make clear
we're talking about this and you know
will smith's the bad guy he is the bad
guy in this situation but i don't really
you don't want to be too passionate in
taking sides because all of these people
you have to understand all the people in
the room they're all scumbags all of
them these are the worst people in the
country all in one room so that's why i
said if they all just beat the hell out
of each other the entire time then um
then really that we're all winners i
guess
but
one of the one of the advan one of the
good things is that now
this incident has given
um the virtue signalers online a new
current thing to care about so what
you're going to find is that all of the
people with ukraine flags in their bio
maybe they keep their ukraine flags
there maybe not but they're all now
going to become alopecia awareness
advocates because that's what this is
boiling down to now jada smith has
alopecia that's why she's bald so this
that's what made the joke so horrible um
and now if you go online you're seeing
all these people talking about alopecia
awareness like for this for example new
york post alopecia advocate praises will
smith's oscars slap he showed strength
quote unquote
says will smith was just defending his
wife jada pinkett smith during sunday
sunday evening's oscar ceremony but for
some who shared the same medical
condition they felt
protected um
ex on the beach contestant zeralina
jackson who also suffers from hair loss
illness and is an advocate on social
media is standing by smith and his
actions at dolby theater
she said i think it's inappropriate to
make any joke about someone with
alopecia as it's a condition that highly
impacts mental health for that
individual and it isn't a laughing
matter
to be clear i don't condone violence but
him defending jada showed strength in my
eyes and was very comforting to see a
man stand by his woman when she has
alopecia well then you are condoning
violence i mean that's literally what
you're doing at least admit you're doing
that
you are condoning violence i don't
condone violence
um
but i think it was strong and brave
for will smith to smack chris rock in
the face okay well then you're condoning
violence that by definition is what
that's what condoning violence sounds
like
when you do that
and there's one other thing too that
because we're hearing this a lot now
that um from from alopecia advocates
which is a
a category that wasn't quite sure
existed but um
and we're hearing that that
well
if you make a joke about someone with
alopecia then you deserve to get
smacked in the face maybe more than that
maybe shot in the head too
but at the same time this is also coming
from people even jada smith herself has
said that's why she has the shaved head
you know she's not wearing a wig or
anything which is which is great which
is fine and she's saying because i'm i'm
proud i'm not ashamed and she shouldn't
be ashamed
and so you're we're getting this from
the alopecia advocates that no we're
proud we're not ashamed of something
shameful totally agree
but you can't have it both ways
you can't say i'm proud i'm not ashamed
but then at the same time if you make a
joke about this you deserve to be
violently assaulted
so i want a special exception for me i'm
proud and not ashamed but i want a
special exception where if you make a
joke about me you can be violently
assaulted
those two things don't really work
together
all right
so um
biden on
friday wrapped up his trip to poland
with a disastrous speech where he called
for regime change in russia something
that nobody around him seems to know
that he was going to do
uh and from what i could tell he had his
scripted speech and at the very end he
decided to go off script and say this
listen
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power god bless you all and may god
defend our free this man cannot be
allowed to remain in power
sounds like you're calling for regime
change
if he's not allowed to remain sounds
like you're saying that uh there needs
to be regime change well the white house
has been trying to clean this up for the
last several days daily wire reports um
uh quoting a white house official the
president's point was that putin cannot
be allowed to exercise power over his
neighbors or the region he was not
discussing putin's power in russia or
regime change right
so that's the line is that when when
biden said this man could not be allowed
to remain to remain in power he meant
he meant that he shouldn't be allowed to
remain in power in ukraine
although he's not in power in ukraine so
it doesn't really make any sense
their way around it is to say
essentially that
joe biden said something he didn't
actually say they're they're just going
to rewrite history which is usually
something that democrats are are able to
do quite easily because they have the
media on their side
only in this case give you an idea how
of how bad this uh
gaff
was if you can call it that
even the media has been calling him out
so here's cnn
just to show you how bad this is here's
cnn
calling biden to the mat for this one
well i'm i think that the policy of this
administration is is not regime change
um unfortunately
the message is confused which is why
president biden i think kind of worked
himself up in this speech and then he
made a comment that he did
you know but the the white house's
response though to say what he really
meant is really gaslighting american
people we know that he really doesn't
want president he doesn't want putin to
be in power and they could have just
said listen we all recognize that putin
is evil what he's doing is evil but the
policy of the united states
is in fact to get to a position of peace
in ukraine and we're going to arm the
ukrainians to make sure they can get to
negotiated peace the other thing i would
say too is this isn't his only gaffe
president biden also made the gaffe
about sending the 82nd airborne into
ukraine which we're not doing and he
also said that the united states would
respond in kind if there was a chemical
weapons attack on the part of russia so
this really was um it was not a good i
think trip for the president because the
three big gaffes really are at cross
purposes with the overall message from
this administration
gaslighting the american people that's
uh that might be
i have to check the guinness records but
i think that might be the first time
that a a democrat has been accused of
gaslighting the american people on cnn
or any
mainstream left-leaning outlet
now we hear the term gaslighting all the
time but it's almost always used about
republicans
that shows you how bad the screw-up was
meanwhile um the other thing that
happened significantly i think over the
weekend relating to ukraine
is that and i can't play any of them
here and i wouldn't play them
but
all kinds of videos started going viral
allegedly showing um pows russian pows
in ukraine being tortured and killed
there's one video in particular multiple
videos but one in particular that's
gotten a lot of attention
appears to show
um
russian or rather ukrainian soldiers
shooting russian pows in the knee caps
where
at least a couple of them proceeded to
die from shock and blood loss as you
might expect
now this is the kind of thing
even though the media as we just saw has
rare moments of almost honesty those
moments are rare and so this is
something that the media is probably not
going to chase down we're not going to
hear a whole lot about
but it does appear that there's
human rights violations war crimes being
committed by ukrainians on film i mean
they're the ones filming this stuff and
posting it online
so war crimes being committed
on top of the fact that that we already
know that in ukraine there are literal
actual nazi militias as part of the
ukrainian forces
and they're the ones committing a lot of
these war crimes
and that's not nazi in the way that we
hear from the media where if you say
something they don't like on twitter
then you're a nazi no no this is like
actual nazis actual neo-nazis
as part of ukrainian forces
so what we're supposed to believe talk
about gaslighting
what we're supposed to believe
is that
the side with
actual nazis
apparently committing war crimes on
camera
is also the side that stands for
democracy and freedom
and that we must be willing potentially
to get into a world war
and lose millions of american lives for
their sake
that's what we're supposed to believe
uh i'm not buying that i have to tell
you i haven't bought it from the
beginning
now i shouldn't have to qualify this and
say it but i will for you know slower
people out there who get confused
there are people who are confused at any
time talking about ukraine if you do
anything but and we're this is still the
case now weeks into this thing if you do
anything but talk about how evil putin
is then uh a lot of some confused people
out there will think that well you must
be supporting putin no i don't support
putin
and or what he's doing or the invasion
of ukraine i want it to be over
i just want the whole thing to be over
i want it to be over for the sake of the
people involved so that there's less
bloodshed and and fewer people die
already far too many people have died
also the sooner it's over the better for
america which is my primary concern
if this thing is over and there's a
peace agreement then that means that
america is not going to potentially get
sucked into it the longer it goes on
it just creates more and more
opportunities for the united states to
get sucked into this especially given
the people running the country right now
our country
um
so i want it to be over i think it's a
terrible thing i think the whole thing
is terrible
but as i said from the beginning when
this when this whole thing first started
what you have to keep in mind
and there there may be a few people
listening right now who are an exception
to this there may be a few people
listening who for years have been
experts on ukraine have been very
interested in that uh region of the
world are familiar with the
long-standing disputes between ukraine
and russia maybe a few people there
maybe like two people listening right
now who fall into that category but
putting you aside everybody else
prior to this happening
you never thought once about ukraine in
your life
you know nothing about the country
whatsoever
you know nothing about the disputes that
leading up to this moment you know
nothing about what precipitated
um russia's
invasion of ukraine
no nothing about any of that
you don't know anything about the the
ukrainian government
that we're supposed to be assisting that
we're sending money to and everything
else
and given that you don't know anything
about it that's why some skepticism is
required
if you don't know anything about it and
everything you're hearing is from the
media
and it's war propaganda
being fed to you by people who you know
you can't trust
who you know you can't trust on any
other issue
do you think war will be different
even otherwise trustworthy and honorable
people can become liars and
propagandists when it comes to war
so what about people who are already
liars and propagandists
what all this means is again it doesn't
mean that we're supporting russia it
just means some restraint some
skepticism
and when you're looking at what's
happening in ukraine right now it's it's
just not as simple as you might want it
to be
if there are war criminals and nazis on
the quote unquote good side that tells
you it's not quite that simple anymore
and it certainly means i don't want a
drop of american i don't want an
american to suffer so much as a paper
cut
in defense of ukraine
if there's even a paper cut that
somebody suffers because of all the cash
that we're handing over to ukraine in
their government their corrupt
government
i'm going to consider that a terrible
tragedy but even that much blood that
much american blood was spilled
for ukraine
all right let's move to this cory booker
is still offended that contangi jackson
was asked what a woman is as we've
established words or violence and so
this was in many ways a violent attack
by marsha blackburn on contagion by
asking her to define what a woman is
cory booker was doing the rounds on the
sunday shows and he still
just totally scandalized by the whole
thing let's listen to that
provide a definition for the word woman
can i provide a definition no the fact
that you
can't give me a straight answer about
something as fundamental as what a woman
is underscores the dangers of the kind
of progressive education
that we are hearing about
what was your reaction when you saw that
moment
i think there were a lot of moments like
that that were deflating to me
um
and disappointing to me
but the reality is
you know
number one she
could have had 22 senators in that room
as opposed to 11 who were asking
questions that were a bit beyond the
pale and she still would have persevered
questions that are beyond the pale
what is a woman is beyond the pale
and of course we're not going to get
from dana bash the follow-up of well can
you define the word since we're on the
subject
this is but cory booker says it's it's
beyond the pale to ask to ask a task a
woman what a woman is
how dare you
and that's that's been the media's line
on this like what they're not going to
do and you'll notice this
from the left
there's been over the last week
especially
there's been discussion about this
question
because they can't help they have to
discuss it they can't totally ignore it
but what they haven't done what i
haven't seen at all is an actual
definition offered
because here's the thing any one of
these people whether it's cory booker uh
anyone i mean the politicians anyone in
the media any left-wing advocate with a
platform
any any of them
could put an end to this
line of attack the line of attack which
is just a basic question they can put an
end to it
by by answering the question by by
giving a definition
if there's one that exists by giving a
definition
that is coherent and that makes sense
and that allows
women to remain as a distinct and unique
category while also
uh not undermining gender ideology
because that like that's the kind of
definition they would need
obviously they don't want to give a
definition that undermines gender
ideology because
that collapses the entire house of cards
they also don't want to give a
definition that erases that explicitly
erases women as a category
what they don't want to come out and say
is is well there's no definition at all
for the word because women aren't
anything they don't want to say that
and because they don't want to say that
then that means that they're that all
they could do is come up with a
definition that somehow threads that
needle and none of them have been able
to do it
because it doesn't exist
i mean they could do that now i mean
i've got the movie i've got a whole
franchise around this question and they
could destroy all of that
ahead of time by just answering the
question i mean how embarrassing would
that be for me
if before i even get the movie out
someone on the left actually comes along
and says okay here's the answer
and then i'm forced to go oh okay well
you had an answer
but they can't because it doesn't exist
that's why i'm personally willing to to
stake my entire reputation such as it is
one reason i'm willing to state my
reputation is because you know i already
have a bad reputation but i'm willing
whatever remains of it i'm willing to
stake it on this because i'm so sure
that a definition that threads the
needle we just talked about doesn't
exist and can't exist
they can call my bluff anytime they can
call marsha blackburn's bluff
um related here aoc was uh talking about
paternity leave and she was doing i
think it's another instagram live um or
this might be might be on tick tock i
don't know but
she has in case you were wondering um
she is also of course bought in entirely
to the idea that um
that you know we can't use the word
mother
that's the that's the m word and that's
offensive and so here's her
language of choice listen
and we do tend to find that for example
um
dads because we give it to all parents
whether you are the birthing parent
adoptive parent whatever um so dads
sometimes like to take that first month
and then their spouses will
um you know
take you know time off and then maybe
they'll try to take additional time off
after their spouse's leave is expired or
they'll take leave while their spouse is
taking leave but it's up to you
the birthing parent is what we're going
with
you know birthing parent
birthing people
there was also something i saw uh on
twitter a couple days ago which was um
and it's not the first time i've seen
this but
the other label that you see sometimes
now is um
bleeders
i mean how much more dehumanizing and
degrading can you get
and the the other funny kind of erotic
thing about this is that
um so often what they'll what you hear
from the left is that well we don't want
to define women by just their body parts
by their you know menstrual cycles by
any kind of physical function that way
because that's very limiting and
that's exactly what they do
literally defining bleeder
reducing women down just to that
or even birthing person
so while they say that i want to reduce
women to their biological functions or
to their body parts that is precisely
exactly what they do
one other thing on a similar note here
it's from the new york post um
it
almost incredible like it's almost hard
to believe this and i i remember i first
saw claims of this online and i thought
uh you know really did they go that far
apparently they did so an image of
controversial transgender swimmer leah
thomas that aired on to the today show
was manipulated to make her well i'm
reading the language from the article
which says her
but it's actually him so i guess i'll
just change that was manipulated to make
him appear more feminine experts said
um
jonathan galagos a former white house
director of digital content president
trump said the edited image has
definitely undergone some sort of
softening and smoothing effect it's
clear this job was not done by a
professional
this level of skin smoothing is a
hallmark sign of an immature job
another photographer said well that's
really bad
so you have photographers people who are
involved in digital editing that have
said that um
that what the the today show actually
doctored an image of leah thomas
in the pool to kind of smooth his
features out a little bit more and make
him look feminine
so they're kind of
after the fact and they also says what
did they do they removed facial
they removed facial lines
skin discoloration
notable red impressions on his face
caused by goggles whatever and blurred
the adam's apple
um the show later ran the original photo
warts and all in a clip posted to
twitter on march 18th
so maybe the today show will try to
defend itself but right now they haven't
said anything about this and they
probably will
try to just ignore it but if they do
have to defend themselves maybe they'll
say this was a rogue editor or something
that did this on their own i'd be very
skeptical of that
but there was a decision made in editing
uh to try to make this guy look more
feminine look more like a woman
and of course even after the
camera tricks and the photoshop he still
looks like a man
a slightly feminized man but still a man
and they do this even though they say
that
there's no reason why having a
prominent adam's apple or you know
having any
traditionally male feature at all should
preclude you from being a woman
they say that and then yet after the
fact they're going to try to you know
give uh
give leah thomas a little bit of an
assist by feminizing him in the in the
post
post edit i mean it's just uh as i said
almost almost surprising almost that
they would go that far
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
all right let's
try uh one video comment let's go to
clip 16.
hello supreme leader walsh i think i may
have done the impossible and
come up with a definition for what is a
woman from the left's perspective and as
always the conservatives have to do
everything for them so i will give you
my definition from a leftist perspective
one who intentionally identifies with or
attempts to physically embody or emulate
or fulfill the social and behavioral
rules generally and historically
attributed in the sign to adult human
females
perhaps
perhaps it works for their perception of
what a woman is supposed to be
i would like you to debunk
my assessment
sweet baby gang for life
uh
it is funny that that i have to say that
the best attempts at coming up with a
definition from a leftist perspective
have all been from conservatives so that
was i'll give you this
um
that's
as good as it's gonna get
and it's it's good because it's a whole
lot of words and i mean you're so you've
learned from from listening to the left
the way the game is played and so you
have a whole bunch of words which are
all trying to obscure the fact that
there's actually nothing being said here
at all so a whole bunch of words and it
makes it sound really complicated and
then in the middle of it you forget
what's even being talked about and then
at the end they say oh see i proved my
point and you say well okay i guess you
did i lost track
um remember i talked about we announced
this film this is this is the
the method of the leftist when it comes
to everything but especially the gender
issues just to get you lost out in the
weeds and so you have
you you have executed
that strategy i think very well
but what you just said really boils down
to i mean if i were to strip away all
the complicated language and the
wordiness of it
what you're saying is that a woman
is a female
or
not a female
that's really what you're saying a woman
is a female or not a female
um which is another way of saying that a
woman isn't anything at all
you know that that is the actual
definition you could you could get rid
of all that
and just say that the leftist definition
of woman
is that it there's no such thing
you know it's kind of a it's a
it's a uh
it's a question based on a false premise
they might say the premise being that
women exist in the first place
i mean that's that's a non that's not a
definition but that is the answer so
that's kind of the answer that you gave
if you were if you were to go deeper
than that uh we would say that there are
also uh some just logical problems there
because what you're saying is that so
you've got
you've got
females who are women according to that
definition i assume right
um
and then people who associate with the
things that are historically associated
with with females and they're also women
and so you have these two people who are
uh distinct from one another
in ways that are that are
immutable
and yet they're exactly the same
according to that definition
so a person who
is something that is is a female
according to that definition is the same
as someone who is not a female
but perceives themselves to be one
so it's just
it doesn't make any sense it's logically
incoherent
but it takes more than a couple of words
i guess to address so that makes it
you know not not bad as far as these
things go
okay justin says well okay reading now
from the comments and uh by the way i
did go
we put up over the weekend um another
one of our
um am i the a-hole
youtube videos where i go to the mia
whole forum on reddit and respond to
some of the quandaries people you know
have situations in their lives where
something happens and they're not sure
if they're the a-hole the way they
responded or if the other person is so
they post these
moral dilemmas on reddit and they get a
lot of bad answers and so every once a
while i'll go and answer some of them
myself and put it on youtube so i'm
reading some of the comments also from
that video as well as the last episode
um
kaiser says i'm glad to see someone
finally spreading awareness about the
discrimination that we free-range
tarantula owners face yeah because one
one of the questions on the mia whole
thing was someone talking about people
bringing their dogs to your house
and i made the point that you know of
course bringing a wild animal to
somebody's house as a guest is
completely inappropriate and we only
would allow that with a dog we don't
make that exception for any other animal
if i worked if i was invited as a guest
to your home
and
i had any pet but a dog and i said can i
bring this pet with me you look at me
like i was crazy if i owned a tarantula
and i said i want to bring my tarantula
with me he's free range he just wanders
around i'm going to bring him into the
living room with me
you look at me like i'm insane you'd say
i'm this is my house it's not a zoo
it's not some kind of nature center
no different for dogs
um
dean says matt must be joking right that
he is walking around his house and shoes
that's something i will never understand
walking around with your nasty shoes in
your house
no i don't walk around
my house and my shoes but my point is
that
if you're if i'm inviting a stranger
into my house i'm not going to require
you to take your shoes off because
number one that means that the first my
first act as the host to you as the
guest is to tell you to remove items of
clothing which is weird
and second it means that now you're
displaying your disgusting feet all over
the place
my feet are one thing it's my house i
can do that i don't want to see your
feet
um
why peffel says i'll finally be getting
a dw subscription just so i can watch
what is a woman
many such cases and now's the chance you
can get 25 off if you go get a
subscription right now with code what is
a woman
uh cool papa j magic says this whole
movement against low self-esteem is not
a good thing low self-esteem is there to
tell you that something is going wrong
and you're not getting the results you
want so it's time to fix it ignoring
that mental state instead of using it as
a motivator to st to solve your problems
will only make you miserable
i totally agree and that actually segues
nicely to what we talk about in the
daily cancellation which we'll get to
now
[Music]
joel osteen is of course the
motivational speaker and self-help guru
who calls himself the pastor of lakewood
church in houston which is co-pastored
by his wife
um victoria
lakewood's website invites you not to a
solemn and sacred celebration of christ
but to the lakewood church experience
with joel osteen
much like an hosting sermon the homepage
does not mention jesus anywhere instead
it promises that at lakewood we believe
your best days are still out in front of
you whether you're joining us in person
or online we invite you to experience
our services and be a part of the
lakewood family the bible says that you
are planted in the house of the lord you
will flourish get ready to step into a
new level of your destiny
so it's all about you your success your
prosperity your destiny
all the religion stuff if it has any
place at all only exists to facilitate
and ensure that your
earthly wealth and happiness come to
fruition
this is the essence of the heretical
prosperity gospel as preached by osteen
and other private jet-flying
televangelists to my knowledge
there's no evidence that osteen's
prosperity gospel has actually helped
any of his congregants be prosperous
certainly not in a spiritual sense but
also not even in a material sense either
prosperity gospel leads to poverty in
every sense of the word and in all worst
senses of the word
it's a different story for the people on
stage peddling this stuff though for
osteen and his wife the whole enterprise
has been enormously profitable
jesus instructed his apostles the first
pastors
to give up everything and follow him
osteen calls himself a pastor and yet
has decided that everything does not
include his opulent 17 000 square foot
estate or his other mansions or his
private jet or as many cars or his 50
million net worth
now there's nothing wrong in and of
itself with being financially successful
but when you're profiting to such an
obscene degree off of your title as
pastor and displaying that wealth and
the most ostentatious way imaginable
it certainly becomes a significant
problem a problem profoundly accentuated
by the fact that the gospel he preaches
and which has made him so rich
has nothing to do with the gospel of
christ
it is a worldly gospel
one focused on material gain
a gospel that promises that faithful
christians will be rewarded with earthly
success and prosperity which of course
would mean that all the many christians
in the world who live in abject poverty
and in misery
i guess just aren't holy or faithful
enough to earn god's blessings
osteen flies over them in his private
jet looking down and yelling at have you
guys tried praying
yet somehow as bad as joel is
his wife the quote-unquote co-pastor who
considers herself qualified to be a
pastor based simply on the fact that her
husband is
manages to be the worst of the two
now victoria just to set stage here
famously preached a few years ago
that christians should live for their
own sake not for god
yes that is explicitly what she said
let's remember this listen
i just want to encourage every one of us
to realize when we obey god we're not
doing it for god i mean that's one way
to look at it we're doing it for
ourselves because god takes pleasure
when we're happy that's the thing that
gives him the greatest joy this morning
so i want you to know this morning
just do good for your own self
feel good because god wants you to be
happy when you come to church when you
worship him you're not doing it for god
really you're doing it for yourself
because that's what makes god happy
amen no not amen do good for your own
self don't worship god for god worship
him for you
because in the end it's all about you
victoria says
and by you she means me victoria really
it's all about the osteens in the end
specifically because they know that this
message though it may be spiritually
toxic is nonetheless the most popular
and appealing and ear tickling message
they could give
there's a lot more money to be made in a
live for yourself message than in a live
for god message
that finally takes us to this past
weekend when victoria
uh the woman who likes to play pastor in
her spare time tweeted this
quote the scripture says let the
redeemed of the lord say so if you're
going to go to the next level you have
to say so if you're going to accomplish
a dream overcome an obstacle or break an
addiction you have to start declaring it
now i'm not exactly sure what she means
by
next level
she giving video game tips now
she might as well claim that scripture
gives advice on how to succeed in mario
kart because her actual claim is just as
absurd and uh just as anachronistic
she says that scripture preaches
self
actualization and self affirmation
calling on believers to believe in
themselves and actualize their own
success by saying it out loud
the problem is that nobody back in
biblical times was superficial or stupid
enough to buy into or even conceive
any of this self-help psychobabble
that line in scripture is not about
chasing your dreams or getting a big
promotion at work in fact nowhere in
scripture are we told that we can make
good things happen for ourselves just by
declaring it
the line that she references is from the
psalms and in context it says give
thanks to the lord for he is good his
loving devotion endures forever let the
redeemed of the lord say so whom he has
redeemed from the hand of the enemy and
gathered from the lambs from east and
west from north and south
so
what are we the redeemed of the lord
saying in this verse are we saying that
we ourselves are special and worthy and
can achieve anything we set our minds to
no the psalms
the psalm calls us to say to declare
that the lord is good not that we are
osteen like so many heretics has skimmed
the bible for one line
removed it from its context
infused it with a modern shallow meaning
and morphed it into a self-help mantra
the kind of thing you say while you're
staring in the mirror rather than
staring at the cross it's not only
heretical but sacrilegious
truly i would rather that she take a
bible and burn it on stage
than take it and turn it into an out of
context self-help bumper sticker
but this was somehow not the worst thing
she put out into the world that day
earlier in the morning on saturday she
posted this
maybe you've made some wrong decisions
but you've made a whole lot of right
decisions too you're better off than you
were in the past and your future is
getting brighter and brighter
see yourself as successful because what
you set your focus on will become
reality
now this is what we might call false
optimism she
breezily declares that you
you as in
everyone all people whoever you are you
are better off today than you were in
the past and your future is brought
she also says that the best way to
become successful is to see yourself as
successful now whether that's the case
or not
let's take the first part of that
prattling nonsense first
you're better off today than you were in
the past your future is bright
okay well
that certainly is not true for everybody
in the world it's probably not even true
for most people
life does not universally follow an
upward trajectory wherein each moment is
better than the last and by simply
existing until this point it's
guaranteed that you've improved over
time and that you will only improve more
in the future that's not reality sad to
say that's not life
that's the version of reality that you
hear from self-help swindlers like
victoria osteen
because she knows that you're more
likely to listen to her and give her
money if she makes you feel good about
yourself
but it's a deluded fragile good feeling
it's not real
it's not grounded in anything true
it won't lead you to true happiness or
contentment because it's a lie it's a
marketing gimmick a sales pitch
see it
it's hard to know what to say to someone
who is really suffering
somebody who's fallen on hard times say
for example a man whose marriage has
collapsed he's lost his family lost his
job his health is deteriorating
that's not some kind of far-fetched
hypothetical
these are the kinds of things millions
of people deal with every day but it's
difficult to come up with a message for
somebody suffering like that
somebody who's encountered real
hardships
so the osteen strategy for dealing with
such difficulties
is simply to pretend that the
difficulties don't exist
they look at this man who has lost
everything and say chin up buddy you're
better off today than yesterday
he had everything yesterday nothing
today how is he better off
in what way
well and how does it help him to say
that to him
well in no way is he better off but the
thin gruel offered by the osteens isn't
substantial enough to nourish someone
dealing with real troubles in life
they have only bumper stickers that's
all nothing else
and so they wave their magic wand and
say abracadabra
and pretend that everything in the world
is good everyone's doing well
and everybody lives in a 20-bedroom
castle just like they do
as for the see yourself as successful
bit that's just terrible career advice
for one thing
you're not going to achieve success in
the future by lying to yourself that
you're already successful when you're
not
and you're not going to be successful
just because you exist like you exist
and you have a job well i'm successful
no you're not
that's baseline that's bare minimum
unless success to you is bare minimum
but if you hunger for more in life then
that's not success
and why would you work for a thing that
you already have
success is not achieved through
self-delusion you're not going to obtain
something by telling yourself you
already have it when you don't
success is not something that you can
speak into existence by repeating a
mantra
it's something you have to work for
work hard every day step by step
it also requires that you humble
yourself
you must admit that you are not as
successful right now as you want to be
if you aren't willing to do that you'll
never achieve what you may have
otherwise been capable of achieving
ironically the osteens themselves
certainly did not achieve their
fantastic financial success by taking
the advice victoria offers
they did it by selling their souls which
is not something that you have to do or
should do if you want to be successful
that was simply their strategy
and in the end i'd say it's why they're
both today
canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
joe biden promises food shortages the
white house tries to muffle biden's war
drums and will smith punches chris rock
at the oscars check it out on the
michael knowles show